good morning Hank it is Tuesday November
8th 2016 it's pizza mess the most
magical time of the year so every year
during pizza miss we make videos on
vlogbrothers every weekday for two weeks
unfortunately Hank you scheduled the
arrival of your child poorly and you're
on paternity leave what's that
apparently you can't schedule the
arrival of a child but pizza miss is
full of magic and so as part of that you
managed to somehow upload a video during
your paternity leave not just a video by
the way but a video with you dancing in
it that's my favorite kind of
vlogbrothers video did you know that
Hank green was named Winter Park High
School's best dancer in 1998 it's true
wait what just happened to my face it's
a pizza mess miracle my mustache is back
also in totally predictable news I have
cut myself shaving by the way I have
been growing a beard for two months for
this joke so I hope you enjoy how
ridiculous I look so the Pizza John
story is so complicated that I can't
even really bring myself to explain it
to new nerdfighters but Hank made a
video a while back with the highlights
but basically every year there's a bunch
of limited edition Pizza John merch like
this year there's this Lacroix Pizza
John there's also this Pizza John hoodie
Hank reached out to a bunch of his
favourite t-shirt designers and many of
them designed awesome Pizza John shirts
you can find them all at dftba.com also
all the Pizza John stuff is only
available during pizza mass and that it
will disappear forever oh god it just
looks so bad with this mustache I look
like a 39 year old man impersonating a
nine year old impersonating a police
officer it's even worse than the one
from last year but you never know what
gifts Pizza Mis is gonna bring wait a
second hold up back up the tape for a
second did I just say it is Tuesday
November 8 2016 ov ember 8 why is that
date important alright it's because the
Pizza John PJ's are being made right
here in Indianapolis on November 8th I
actually prefer to call them the PJ PJ's
alright I gotta head over to the pajama
Factory and for better or worse I'm
taking my mustache with me quick story I
didn't get this on video because I'm a
bad vlogger who's terrified of pulling
out his camera in public places except
for airports but I just got a cup of
coffee and after I ordered the woman
behind the counter said I must ask you
if you would like room for cream and I
just want to say for the record
well-played
all right Hank I've arrived at crazy
clothes time to go see my pajamas I'm
John micronesia yeah that's what you
sofirst Debbie lays out the fabric then
it goes through this amazing machine
where it is imprinted with my
mustachioed face now there are some
parts of the process that are automated
but
every pair of Pizza John pajamas is cut
and sewn by hand right here in
Indianapolis and when they're all done
they look like this I think that's all I
had scheduled for November 8th just
kidding I have to go vote are detected
myself my sample ballot by the way on my
phone I've got this great pizza John pop
socket it's so useful never not self
promo in quick sidenote if you're an
American and you can vote listen to the
man with the mustache look up your
polling place in the doobly-doo if you
need to refresher on anything you might
need to bring to the polls go to
youtube.com slash how to vote in every
state and look up your state and go vote
you can do this I'm about to do it with
a mustache wearing a portrait of myself
with a mustache okay I'm on my way into
my polling place and now I have voted
again if you need voting resources you
can find some in the doobly-doo below
happy pizza miss and happy Election Day
I'm not gonna lie I'm a little bit
nervous but I'm just I'm just trying to
keep my cool Who am I kidding I'm a lot
bit nervous Hank I will not see you
tomorrow but I'll see somebody on
vlogbrothers vote